petit quiz sont au vert de loire pièce
qui pèse trois tonnes est arrivé ici
dans la tanière en eure-et-loir en 2020
après avoir quitté l'allemagne les kane
trompe 200 kg c'est bien sûr ce etc
c'est valentin c'est moi non c'est pas
toi n'ont pas tari vitres auto la ccl
rajendra mais vu que tu es le soigneur
de rejoindre actu va nous parler de
rejoindre à ok il est trop tôt quatre
mois après
alors valentin tué soigneur donc ici à
la tanière et donc on a un jeune rat et
sony sonnailles sunaryo voilà je
prononce pas tu vois pas très bien est
ce que tu peux nous raconter leur
histoire leur parcours du coup arsenal
c'est le premier éléphant qui arrivait à
la tanière donc il arrivé le 2 septembre
2020 il nous vient du zoo de rotterdam
il arrivé à l'âge de 5 ans deux jours
après on a eu ras joindra donc du zoo de
cologne en allemagne lui résoudra tout
simplement ils arrivent à sa maturité
sexuelle et quand on est en captivité
quand on a un groupe d' éléphant souvent
on a que ce qu'un seul mâle reproducteur
d'accord et alors pour éviter tout de
suite encore les conflits entre les
éléphants il faut pouvoir déplacer ses
éléphants pour que justement tout se
passe bien dans une famille et bientôt
il ya un nouvel animal qui va arriver mi
congolais me picard ça s'appellera
kamini faudrait bien de soigner 1
quel est le programme du soigneur c'est
quoi la journée classique et bah quand
on arrive c'est un petit bonjour aux
éléphants derrière on va faire des
prises de température donc buccale
travail différentes maladies chez les
éléphants une fois qu'on a fait ce petit
chèque on prépare l'enclos et puis après
on les laisse vaquer à leurs occupations
nous c'est ce qu'on aime quand on sort
nos éléphants il faut leur vie ils n'ont
pas besoin de nous et
nous après on prépare tout on nettoie
une fois que c'est fait généralement
chez les éléphants ont fait un médical
training et là on va s'occuper beaucoup
du des pieds des éléphants en faire du
parage au niveau des six est très
important c'est simple l'endroit ne
doivent pas se glisser dans la nature un
éléphant il marche 12 à 14 heures par
jour pour chercher sa nourriture en
captivité forcément il va - marché donc
il va - lisez cette soul la soul c'est
ce qu'on a sous le pied de l'éléphant et
nous du coup on veille à la bonne santé
de la soul qui aucune impuretés un
caillou ou autres qui s'infiltrent dans
le pied qui se ferme qui peut créer une
infection et un observent même l'intrus
qui m'interpelle je vois il tombe ça
trompe comme ça et il soulève nerb il ya
une précision et une dextérité qui est
assez impressionnante ouais c'est ça
donc l'éléphant d'asie au bout de sa
tron qui va avoir un doit donc qui est
très agile se tromper assez fascinante
chez l'éléphant dire qu'il va pouvoir
attraper 1 900 cas c'est par contre
bouger une charge de 250 à 300 kg est
aussi possible alors tiens quand même à
préciser à nos téléspectateurs que je ne
suis pas si petit et n'est pas si grand
que ça a c'est juste que le sien en
contre-plongée pas parce que moi je veux
je sens déjà je sens la vue
je sais aussi c'est à dire on
parle en anglais 3c langage universel
voilà bah non nous on n'accueille que
des mâles et aux musicales training du
coup on va s'exprimer en anglais ce sont
des éléphants qui sont voués à aller
dans d'autres structures pour se
reproduire donc on utilise tout
simplement le langage universel jeu mais
reculent en même temps que je parle
toujours d'amour
derrière valentin et donc la cc on se
dit d'hydratation césar donc un élément
adultes va boire minimum 100 litres
d'eau par jour disney + fois la peine de
tribu parce qu'un homme des hauts de
france peut voir 100 litres de bière par
jour
il encaisse très bien j'en connais
beaucoup je connais beaucoup donc
l'éléphant c'est boire tout seul
évidemment et ça c'est un moment qu'ils
apprécient de donner de l'eau fraîche ou
tuyaux directement un moment qu'on passe
aussi avec eux d'une clause c'est que du
bonus voilà et ben valentin merci
beaucoup c'est à toi merci pour tout je
tiens à monter sur la plaque d'égout
pour montrer que je suis pas plus petit
que valentin j'étais vraiment pencher
tout à l'heure pour des raisons de
sécurité je vois je réexplique passe ici
je sens ils vont rigoler kamini les
petites ou non volantes à merci à grand
plaisir ok merci merci saluera joindre à
sa vie sous dit toujours ce bail